sí muy interesante buenas tardes ayer ya
escuchamos a uno de ellos y hoy
escuchamos a álex escarlatas es el
primero de los dos militares que
lograron reducir ayuda al cazan y
básicamente su relato se parece mucho a
la película de clint eastwood que cuenta
lo que pasó en ese tren pero hoy hubo un
dato interesante él explica que quitó el
arma al terrorista y que lo apunto y le
dijo por favor deja de resistirse lo
repitió varias veces pero como el
terrorista no hizo caso el disparo
contra yuval cassani pero el arma estaba
vacía y él dice que en ese momento de
ellos se sintieran muy frustrados sino
al final la audiencia terminó de manera
intempestiva fue suspendida por 10
minutos ya que el abogado del propio
estadounidense le recordó que la defensa
del terrorista está haciendo circular
informaciones que lo vinculan a él con
la derecha con el partido republicano
que fue candidato a las elecciones por
el partido republicano pero también con
la extrema derecha y de hecho él vio por
ejemplo las semillas de la película
junto al expresidente ahora o presidente
ya
donald trump y que él para él había sido
un honor él reconoció efectivamente su
vinculación con el partido republicano
pero descartó que esté vinculado a la
extrema derecha dijo que eso fue un
montaje que hicieron en su contra y dice
que esa vinculación política que él
tiene no tiene nada que ver con el
atentado en el que él participó del que
fue víctima pues recordemos que la
defensa del terrorista en todo momento
ha dicho que él se arrepintió como
decías tú muy bien ya se arrepintió de
este ataque y que en realidad había
subido solamente a dar muerte a los
estadounidenses a este tren